time the clock strikes midnight tuesday
lawmakers will determine if they will
or will not pass a massive coronavirus
relief package before election day
after months of negotiation speaker of
the house nancy pelosi says
if lawmakers don't come together by
today relief may have to wait until
after the election
republicans are drafting a backup plan
washington correspondent raquel martin
has more on the ongoing battle
deal or no deal that's the question
swirling on capitol hill
as lawmakers have until midnight to come
up with a bipartisan coveted relief plan
we've got to get this done democrats
like illinois congresswoman sherry
bustos
are hoping republicans sign onto
democrats more than 2
trillion proposal small businesses need
our help
families need our help that 1200 dollar
stimulus check
is needed right now president trump is
urging his party to go
big on a plan but many republicans are
still concerned about spending too much
i don't think we ought to give any more
money to state and local governments
but i wouldn't say no to a whole package
if it's a more reasonable figure
iowa republican senator chuck grassley
says he supports this in its two
targeted bills
one to extend the paycheck protection
program and another 500 billion
plan to fund schools the unemployed and
vaccines
we're proposing this not as a ticket or
leave it to the democrats
but a suggestion from republicans on
where there's already bipartisan
agreement spare me
illinois democratic senator dick durbin
and iowa democrat cindy axne say the
targeted options
don't do enough no funding for housing
or rental assistance and people are
wondering is it possible we're going to
see a twelve hundred dollar check
well you won't see it in senator
mcconnell's proposal we've got a big
problem and we can't fix it with a
skinny bill durbin is calling on
republican congressional leaders to hold
out for a bipartisan deal
with the white house in washington
raquel martin
meantime here at home in terms of
getting financial help right now
clark county recently launched a new
website for the cares housing assistance
program or
chap so people who suffered financial
hardship due to the virus
can now apply but they must show
documented proof
of that hardship and also meet some
other criteria
the county says the most important thing
to do right now is to go to
chap.clarkcounty.gov
and put your name in the system to get
that process going